- Hello, everyone
and welcome back.
My name is Yukio Lippit.
I am the Faculty
Director of the Arts
at the Radcliffe Institute,
and a co-organizer
of this conference, which is
titled Game Changers: Sports,
Gender, and society.
I'd like to offer just
a few brief comments.
Before introducing our
next two speakers--
the conference keynote speaker
Leila Ali in conversation
with our moderator
Christine Brennan.
Now we trust that
by now if you've
been following the
conference you share
the conviction of the
organizers that the relationship
between sports, and gender,
and society is complex and ever
evolving, and that now
seems to be a particularly
opportune moment to
reflect upon and re-examine
its many dimensions.
This morning, we
heard a panel that
did so from a historical
perspective, framed, of course,
through a consideration of
the consequences of Title IX,
and what it means for athletic
participation and gender
equality.
This panel included a
really beautiful meditation
on this idea of sports
as a birthright--
as somehow a
fundamental part of what
it means to be human, of
sports as a basic part
of the human experience,
and the challenges
that have faced women and
people with disabilities
in staking a claim to it.
We also heard in the late
morning in the panel on Gender
and Wellness of a host of
perspectives on this issue from
the NCAA perspective, from
the US anti-doping agency,
and community sports, and
how to think about gender--
the issue of gender
and difference
in sports from
myriad perspectives--
neurophysiological,
biomechanical.
From the perspective of the--
from legal, cultural, social.
We also learned why the
Scandinavian countries
are the happiest in the world.
Later this afternoon, we'll be
exploring yet a different set
of issues in the panel Gender,
Media, and Popular Culture.
It goes without saying
that we have now
been living in a saturated
media culture for some time
now from that
moment that was so,
I think, well captured
in the movie Anchorman 2
when Ron Burgundy,
played by Will Ferrell,
is being recruited
during the 1980s
by an executive for a new
24-hour news channel, GNN.
And blurts out, that
is without doubt,
the dumbest thing
I've ever heard.
You might say that the
afternoon panel examines
what happens in the wake
of the emergence of GNN,
and more generally of sports
through the culture of sports,
the fandoms, the
media practices,
and the popular culture
with which sports
have become so imbricated.
Now as a conference
organizer, I can
tell you that the
Radcliffe institute is
this interesting place where the
faculty directors get together
with the dean and administrators
and propose conference themes.
Then, we propose an absolutely
improbable dream list of world
experts to address them.
And then we go out and ask
them, and they say yes,
and here we are.
Amazing.
And nowhere is this
more the case than
with our keynote
speaker, Laila Ali.
She needs no introduction.
And you will find in
our conference booklets
an extensive bio for her,
as with all of our speakers.
But let me just say that
in a remarkably wide
ranging achievements and
experiences as a boxing
champion and world class
athlete, actress, commentator,
and past president of the
nonprofit Women's Sports
Foundation, Laila Ali
has lived or embodied
in one form or another
many of the issues that we
are addressing in
today's conference.
She is an advocate
for equality for women
in the world of
professional sports
who is both powerful
and thoughtful.
Someone who will be
able to offer unique
perspectives on
the many questions
that emerge at the intersection
of sport and gender.
And we are absolutely delighted
and privileged to have her
here.
And it was a tall order to
find an interlocutor who
could activate to the fullest
this opportunity for engagement
with Laila Ali,
but we have somehow
found the ideal person--
Christine Brennan, an award
winning national sports
columnist and best selling
author whose pioneering status
in sports journalism offers
her equally unique insights
into the issues we've been
addressing throughout the day.
And she has just flown in from
a blustery day in Augusta,
Georgia, covering the
Masters to be here with us,
and it's a real honor to be
able to have her join us today.
And before welcoming
them to the stage,
let me explain how
this will proceed.
After Laila Ali and
Christine Brennan
conclude their conversation,
we will take questions
from the audience.
A mic will be placed
in the central aisle,
and we ask that you
come up to the mic,
introduce yourself before
asking your question.
Now I'm just going to linger
here for just a few seconds
because I'm pretty
sure that this
is the only time
in my life that I'm
going to be able to
introduce a world renowned,
undefeated boxing champion.
Without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Laila Ali and
Christine Brennan to the stage.
- Thank you.
- Wow.
Is my mic on?
Yes.
How are you doing?
I'm really excited to be here.
Honored to be here.
I've already learned
a couple new words--
words I need to go
look up, thank you.
But thank you so much to Dean
Elizabeth Cohen for inviting
me, and like I said,
I'm honored to be here,
share my story with you.
Looking forward to
discussing my story with you.
I just want to start by
saying that I think all of us
know that now more than
ever, we're living in a time
where women, especially,
need to be inspired
to find that greatness within
themselves that we all have.
I think that we're champions.
We're warriors.
We're definitely athletes.
We know that.
That's what I love about sports.
I love that sports can
be a vehicle for us
as women to find all of
those leadership qualities
that are there.
One of the biggest
regrets that I have--
I have very few, aside
from some of the guys maybe
in the past I've dated,
but one of the biggest
regrets that I have is that I
didn't play sports growing up.
A lot of people
assumed that I did.
They also assume that I got
into boxing because my father is
the greatest of all
time, but I actually
didn't want to
box myself until I
saw women boxing on
television for the first time.
And I remember that moment
like it was yesterday.
I was in complete awe, and
wanted to do it myself,
so I think of that now
as me being an athlete
and a role model to
other girls growing up.
Not even necessarily to want
to become a boxer, but just
expanding our minds of
what's possible for us to do.
So, again, I'm honored to
speak to you all here today,
and I would love to go through
that story with you guys.
- All right.
Well, what a great
opening statement.
And I was saying-- we were
just in the green room--
I was saying, you know that
thing, the school yard thing--
like, my, dad can take your dad.
That wasn't so good.
Maybe my mom could
take your mom.
- Probably not that either.
I'm just joking.
My mom's a little feisty.
- My mom was too.
OK.
I'm 0 for 2.
You talked to your dad.
And when we were
chatting a few days ago
just to kind of prepare
for this, and what
a wonderful scene this is to
see all of you in this gym,
in this historic setting.
The old boys' club of
Augusta National or here?
I think I should just stay here.
All right.
I'll stay.
But we were talking,
and I said, is it
OK you talk about your dad?
And you said, of course.
And there's so many
ways we could go
with the greatest of all time--
Mohammad Ali-- but you
just touched upon it.
So you did not really play--
you didn't play sports.
You didn't think
you'd be a boxer,
and as I recall, your dad
was not exactly thrilled
when you said, hey dad,
I want to be a boxer.
Why don't you tell
everyone that story
because I think
it's illustrative
of not only, of course,
your personal story,
but also of a girl trying
to say to a dad, hey,
I want to play sports, and the
dad kind of being reluctant,
and then obviously
finally coming around.
Right?
- Well for me.
I'm not just any girl, and
it wasn't just any dad.
This is Muhammad Ali, the
greatest of all times.
He has his youngest
daughter now wanting to box.
So he didn't have
any of his kids.
I don't think he wanted
any of his kids to box.
We can go into that
later, but as a fighter,
I wouldn't want my
kids to box, either.
So it's just one
of those things.
But for me, I
decided that I want
to start training after I saw
women's boxing on television.
And I was in school full
time, and I had a business--
I had a nail salon
because I started
going to school to learn how
to do nails when I was 16.
And I built up my clientele,
saved up my money,
I was subleasing.
And I had this whole
plan, and I'm a planner.
So I was like, I'm
going to go to school,
I'm going to live on
my own, which I did.
And I'm going to focus on
building this business.
And then all of a sudden
I see women's boxing
and I'm like within myself--
- How did you see it.
You watch it on TV.
- I turned on television to
watch a Mike Tyson fight,
and I wasn't a big boxing fan,
but I watched the big fights,
and then here come these women
into the ring on the under
card.
So I think that was the
first time a lot of people
saw women's boxing, and
that moment-- that's when
the seed was planted within me.
And I remember saying,
I want to do that.
And I was with my best friend
and her father, he said Laila,
those women will
take your head off.
And I was like, no, I can do it.
I can do it.
But then when I went home,
and the fear and the doubt
started to set in, and I don't
know if I'd be able to do it,
meaning change my plans.
You know, I've told everybody.
I've said this is
my plan, and then
what are they going to say?
What are they going to think?
Just all of that.
I was a young girl.
But that feeling
did not go away,
so I thought about it
for I think about a year.
I'm really bad with timelines,
but it took us about a year.
And then I decided,
you know what,
I'm going to go find a
trainer and start training.
And I did it all on my own.
I didn't ask my dad for help.
I was still trying to figure out
if it was something I actually
wanted to do-- if I
had the talent to do,
because I knew I was going to
be successful with this nail
business and become
an entrepreneur,
and boxing was so new for me.
So I went to the gym,
started training,
and at a certain point my
father found out about it,
and I had already
decided that yes, I
was, in fact, going to do it.
And that's when he asked me--
came in town, because he didn't
live in Los Angeles-- and said,
you know, I hear
that you're boxing,
and you're going
to start fighting.
I was like, yeah I am.
He basically tried to talk
me out of it indirectly.
That's how my father-- he
brings up every negative thing
that he possibly can.
What happens if you
get knocked out?
get knocked down?
The whole world's going
to be watching you,
and all my answers
was based on-- well,
when you got knocked
down, you got back up.
I don't think I want to get
knocked out, but if I do,
I'm going to ask for a rematch.
You know, I gave
all these answers,
like what else could he say?
And he knew he was
talking to Laila,
and he knows Laila is going
to do what she wants to do.
He was like, OK, he knew he
couldn't tell me not to do it,
so we had that talk.
And I just said, hey, you're
either going to support me,
or you're not.
And he made it very clear
that he didn't really
think women should be fighting.
My father was a little
bit of a male chauvinist,
and so that was
something I was like,
I'm not going to try to change
your mind about that, other
than I'm going to show
you what I can do.
I'm going to show
you that I can do it.
So I started boxing.
And needless to say--
maybe I do need to say it--
I did change his mind about it.
Know He was like, wow,
you really can fight.
Women can fight.
He had a whole different
thought in his mind
when it came to
women in the ring.
- Did he come to
any of your fights?
- He did.
He was at most of my fights.
He didn't make it to all of
them just because he was sick
and couldn't always be
there, but he was there.
Over half of the
fights he was there.
- So when he showed up, did
he try to sneak in the back?
- Oh my dad?
No.
- Right.
- Every time he walked in
it was like, Ali, Ali, Ali,
and he loved it.
- That's good for you because
the crowd was on your side.
- Well yeah, but the crowd--
was what was surreal about my
boxing career was just that I
felt like I was
fighting for both of us,
because he couldn't-- just with
his Parkinson's-- and I knew I
could see in his eyes he would
love to be back in that ring
again and he couldn't.
So I felt like I was
kind of doing it for him
and he was living
through me, as well.
So when he walked
in and everyone
started chanting Ali and
then again when I came out.
I never really
focused on my dad when
whether he was going to be there
or not because as a fighter,
I like to just really be
focused on the mission at hand.
I can't worry about
who's in the audience.
None of that.
And then after the fight,
I always looked for my dad
and just kind of see that joy
and excitement in his eyes.
- And when you look
at him, was it--
again, I know, he was
gradually losing the abilities
that obviously made him who
he was, but his personality--
I mean, did you
see it in his eyes?
- Oh yeah.
- What would he do to
show you how much he
was loving what you
were doing after being
so reluctant at first?
- Well, my father--
well, first of all, he told me
that he had a change of heart.
So I changed his mind
about just not just me,
but women in general
being able to fight.
He had to get past-- my father
is Muslim, and I'm not--
and a lot of people
assume that I am,
but that was an issue
just wearing a sports bra
and shorts in the ring with him.
And I was like, dad, really?
That's what you're
thinking about?
But just being able to watch
me in the ring as a fighter
and not seeing a woman, per
se, but seeing a fighter.
And he knows that you
have to respect the game.
He knows how hard it is to train
and to prepare and all of that,
and it has nothing to do with
being a woman or being a man.
So just for him to be able
to see past all of that
and show me my respect,
and at the same time,
be so surprised because he
wasn't there to see me train.
He didn't know when
he was going to see.
And then to be able
to see the way that I
was able to dominate.
And then, of course, it's
like, you're just like me.
Now you want to take credit, OK.
- So a few years after this,
through Billie Jean King
and everyone at the
Women's Sports Foundation--
some of the folks have
been around obviously here
at the conference--
the wonderful Women's
Sports Foundation,
which does so much good work,
they basically kind of twist
your arm and pretty soon you're
president of the Women's Sports
Foundation.
That's Billie Jean King for you.
- She got me good.
- Right, you say
hello, and now you're
president of the Women's
Sports Foundation.
She knew what she was doing
because of your personality,
because of everything that
you've just described for us.
So what did you take from your
personal experience and taking
a dad-- in this case the
most famous dad in the world,
one of them--
and turning him
around and saying,
hey, you can look at me as
an athlete, not as a girl.
It's not just a girl
playing a sport.
This is an athlete playing--
what did you then take,
and how did that
help you as you then
went to this global role of
being the face of women's
sports for a couple of years?
- This is one of those
questions I'm going to answer,
and I get so deep I I'm going
to forget what the question was.
- It's OK, that's why I'm here.
- Thank you.
- Now if I forget,
we're in trouble.
- Right, right.
The thing is that the way I
approach my career and life
is that I never really worried
about what my dad thought,
or what anybody else thought.
I worried about what I
thought about myself.
So for me, I had something
to prove to myself first,
and I have really high
expectations of myself.
So with my father,
I was just like--
I've always been confident.
I know I get that same
confidence from him
because I had been training,
and I knew what I could do.
I had already proved to
myself that I can do this,
and I can be a champion, and
you're just going to sit back
and you're going to watch.
So for me, I was not
really concerned even
with him going in because
it didn't hurt my feelings.
I wasn't like-- I can't
believe my own father is
not-- it's just like,
look, peace, see you later.
I'm about to go do this,
and you can come along
for the ride or not.
So that was one thing
that took the burden off
of myself to feel like
I had to please my dad
or change his mind.
I felt like that was
going to happen naturally,
and that's the same
way that I've just
approached the sport and life.
It's too much to have
to worry about what
everybody else is thinking.
If I just stay focused on what
my goals are and be in the best
that I can be because that
takes so much energy and focus
and dedication to begin with,
then you can't do anything
but change your mind
at the end of the day
because it is what it is if
you're honest with yourself.
You know, so I think that
that's what changes--
when people think women
can't do something,
you see someone
do it, they think
they can't because maybe
they've never seen it before,
but as soon as you see it,
you learn something new,
it changes that information.
You're like, oh, so
I think right now
my focus is just being
the best that I can be,
and then inspiring
others along the way.
But I try not to put that burden
on myself of I have to do this,
and I have to do that, and I
have to please this person.
I think that a lot
of times as women
sometimes we do that
because we feel--
and that's not to say that
I don't feel responsible
and I don't make smart
choices along the way,
because I do take being a
public person and a role model
very seriously.
There's opportunities
that come up that I have,
and I'll turn them down
just because of the way
it might come off, or
just because the message
that it might send.
Even though it might be
something I'm OK doing,
I always have to think
about the long term effect.
And I don't know if
anyone's ever noticed,
but you don't really ever
see me showing too much,
or having too much cleavage out.
And a lot of people might
assume it's because I'm Muslim.
I'm not.
It's just that I don't
like for young girls
to feel like you
have to pose nude,
or you have to do
certain things.
And at the same time, there
are some women that do it,
and I don't judge them for that.
Maybe they choose to do that,
but that's not who I am,
and that's not the image
that I want to send.
So here we are, and what
was the question again?
I have so much I want
to say, I was like--
- No, no.
Actually there's some
really great nuggets
of things I'd love to pursue.
But the Women's Sports
Foundation and being
the president-- so
now you've got this--
I was at the dinner
and you're speaking,
and you're the face
of women's sports.
You're no longer the
boxer, you've now
graduated to this global role.
I guess the question was, your
experience and how then you
were able to say, if the field
hockey people came to you
or if someone--
can maybe give us, if there
were moments-- maybe not--
of where you gave advice,
or you were in meetings,
or you could see sports
starting to emerge,
which we see in the
Olympics all the time.
Obviously we see in the
NCAA women's basketball.
And now this is your
entire landscape
that you are involved with
for a couple of years.
- So when Billie Jean
first approached me
about being the president of
the foundation, I was reluctant,
and hesitant because
I was like wow,
I didn't even grow
up playing sports.
And there's so much there
as far as just organized
sports and collegiate
sports and all these things.
And just never played
it, and there's just
this whole vocabulary
that goes along with it.
I can't even really
have the conversation.
So I was like, I don't
know if I'm the one.
She's like, no you are the one
because you're that person.
We want to get more
girls involved in sports,
and you're someone who's
saying that I regret
that I didn't play sports.
And you see the importance
of it, and how it could have
enriched my life, right?
So I was like OK, I'll do it.
And, of course, then
being around all
these different women and
sitting in board meetings
and listening to all the
issues is really overwhelming.
But the fact that we're
in a time when we still
see all the
disparities, then that
means that we need strong
women that can stand up
and can say something
that can inspire others.
So it doesn't
really matter what I
did and didn't do,
as long as I can have
that conversation with people.
So yes, now I'm an
advocate for sports,
even though I didn't
play it growing up.
I'm like, no, my kids
are going to play sports.
I want the confidence building--
what you learn about
yourself-- the discipline,
working as a team.
All these things
you learn in sports
that you can apply to so many
different areas of your life.
All of these successful
women that I've met
said they believe that a
large part of their success
is because they played sports.
You learn so much about
yourself and about the world
through sports.
And as we've been
talking about--
I know you guys
have been talking
about the importance
of it, and how
it kind of plays into society
in so many different ways
and all of that.
And it's true, and
I've seen that myself.
So that's why I think
Billy asked me to be
a president of the foundation.
I will always be involved
with the Women's Sport--
because once you get
in, you don't get out.
Once you get in--
- It's like the
Hotel California.
- Right, right.
- Here we are, the
45th anniversary
of Title IX in a
couple of months.
And so many good things,
as you mentioned.
But what you touched on a
few moments ago about the way
you handle yourself,
and the way you dress,
it is fascinating isn't it?
Because you talked to some
young athletes who maybe appear
in the ESPN Body Issue, or even
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue, which tends to be almost
all-female, where the ESPN Body
Issue is actually male
and female, which I think
is better.
But they're like hey,
no problem, right?
And I'm reminded of back in--
Jenny Thompson, the
great Olympic swimmer
who posed topless with her
arms like this or whatever
in Sports Illustrated.
I asked Donna de Varona--
the great Donna de Varona--
the Olympic gold medalist.
And she said, I
kind of like it when
they keep their clothes on.
And so you know, there's
kind of like that old school
feeling, right?
But we also want to understand
that these women believe
it's a sense of freedom,
even if us old people--
not you, me-- would
go, wait a minute,
you're playing to the lowest
common denominator, which
is, the male gaze,
or you're playing
to that male dominated
sports world.
So when you talk
to a young person--
I assume you do some
mentoring, do you
find that young girls are
receptive to this, they want
to hear what you have to say?
Or they're kind of
like, hey, that's great,
but I'm going to
do my own thing,
and if I'm sleeveless
every day of the year
and wearing almost no
clothes, no problem.
And how do we make sense
of that, do you think?
- Everyone has a right to
make their own decision,
I just try to offer them
a different alternative.
I think that you can--
you naturally as a woman want
to be-- you want people to say,
oh you're pretty, and sometimes
people go to different lengths
in order to get that response.
They want to sometimes show
their body in a magazine
and be nude so people go,
oh, my God, did you see her?
And maybe something else
will come from that.
Or maybe they have
people around them,
like their agents, that
are like, no you can do it.
You're an athlete, this
is an athletic thing.
So it just really
depends on whether or not
you can do it and sleep at
night, and for me that's
not something that I ever wanted
to do because I feel like you
can be just as strong
and you can be beautiful,
and you can be powerful
with your clothes on.
But some people
feel like they want
to make a statement by
taking their clothes off.
To each their own.
But with the young
girls, I try to just--
I think that if you love
yourself and you have
confidence in yourself, and
you know what your values are,
then it will be easier
to make those decisions
when you're faced with them.
Because there is going
to come a time when
you're going to have to decide.
- Right, and you think
about, for example,
Brandi Chastain with the winning
penalty kick in '99 and she
takes off her shirt, and
twirls it over her head.
An iconic moment, and you see
her abs and how cut she is.
And then people say, oh, well
that this a sign of sex--
or whatever that was--
and then the flip side is, well,
there were probably millions
of women that exact
day on the beach--
it was July 10 of 1999--
women throughout the
country on the beach
with less on than Brandi
had at that moment.
So these conversations, I think,
are with us probably forever.
- And I didn't have
a problem with that.
She just took off for shirt.
She had sports braw underneath.
It was just a moment.
I don't think she really
thought that through.
I'm going to take off my shirt
and show them how sexy I am.
Lot of times male athletes
will take off their shirt,
and they can.
But she happened to
have a sports bra,
so that was a little different.
- And she was a big soccer fan.
As she explained for
anyone who hasn't followed
this thing since I opened this
up, she watched men's soccer.
And when they score a big goal,
they take their shirt off.
And so she said, why not?
And then she did, too.
And that was a pretty big goal,
I think we can safely say.
Cover of Time, Newsweek,
people and Sports Illustrated.
No story in the
history of stories
has ever been on the
cover of Time, Newsweek--
not even your dad has been on
the cover of Newsweek, People,
and Sports Illustrated.
Well, I don't think
People existed maybe
when he was doing his thing.
That's my story.
I'm sticking with it.
But that's how big
a deal that was.
- Wow.
- You know Julie Foudy?
You know some of those guys--
the women's soccer team.
I actually competed
against Brandi
on Chopped--
cooking competition.
- And who won?
- I won.
She wasn't the only one.
I think it started out with four
people or something like that.
- Anyone who wants to beat
out Brandi Chastain, I
heard you just lost.
- She was so good, though.
She really was.
And she made a minor mistake.
And, no, seriously-- she
made a minor mistake.
No, in her defense--
because I thought it was going
to be her and I in the finals,
and she burned
herself, and I think
that got her so flustered that
she forgot to put her sauce
or something on.
If you don't watch
Chopped, you wouldn't
know what I'm talking about,
but she left out an ingredient,
and that automatically
gets you out.
But she could have won it.
I was watching her like--
OK, I got to watch her because
she was doing her thing.
- On my notes here, I
didn't have Chopped.
But, what you just said--
so here we are, and
we're talking about you
and we're talking
about Brandi, and we're
talking about crossing
over into our culture,
and we all know exactly
what we're talking about.
And generation ago, it was
Billie Jean, or Chris Evert--
maybe a generation and a half.
But there are so many women now
who we have a household name--
Mia Hamm, how about
women's hoops?
The entire women's Olympic
basketball team, Mia Moore,
on and on and on it goes.
I mean, I'm bullish about
where women's sports is.
I mean, it's interesting
time in our country.
You may have heard
there was an election.
Where do women stand?
But I'm really-- I think
the glass is half full,
and I'm very positive.
Are you?
- I am, yes--
especially when we're
talking about women's sports.
I just love that we see women
in every sport now pretty much.
And I love that my
son is growing up
where he can see women boxing,
he can see women in the UFC,
he can see women wrestling, he
can see women playing football.
He's out there on the field
playing soccer with girls.
My daughter is on his
baseball team right now.
So just that they're going
to open up their mind
and not think.
That's where it starts with us
just at a very young age where
we've been conditioned
to think a certain way,
and that there's the
possibilities that are there.
So I think that this
newer generation of kids
will grow up thinking different.
- What you're describing--
you're racing not only of Title
IX female, but a Title IX male.
- Yes, definitely.
- And I don't know if many
of you thought about this,
but you think of these young
men at this certain age,
and for example, the USA--
we talked about it at lunch--
USA women's hockey.
The big battle they just
had and a major victory
that they had in terms of wages.
Well who jumped in right away,
but the NHL players and Major
League Baseball.
And we're talking about men and
women in their 20s, basically,
so they're born in the '90s.
So those Major League
Baseball players
were exactly like your son--
watching their sisters
cheering for them,
or the girl next door.
They were playing sports.
- I don't know about
you, but I think
this is such an under reported,
kind of under the radar
piece of our culture that I
don't talk about in my columns.
Do you feel like
we're maybe missing it
as some of these issues
that it just isn't quite as
popular as talking
about whatever else
is going on in the world?
- I hadn't thought
of that question,
but now that you
asked me, yes, I think
it needs to be covered more.
So maybe we need to start that
conversation, keep it going.
- What else do we
need to cover more?
I am looking for a column
idea for next week.
- I just gave you one.
Take that one.
- I know, exactly.
We said we wanted to have
a conversation here--
and by the way, we've got
about 15 minutes or so,
and then we definitely want
to take your questions,
so that is the most
important thing--
and we can actually even go to
questions sooner, if we want.
If you're sick of my
questions, we can go on--
- No, like your questions.
- One thing that I have
fun thinking about,
and so I'll kind of
start the conversation--
what's it all going to look
like in 50 years or 100 years?
Where will women be?
The 10-year-old girl today--
or how old is your daughter?
- My daughter just turned
six a couple of days ago.
- There you go-- your
six-year-old daughter.
When she is 46--
40 years from now-- what
does this world look like.
There's no wrong
answer, obviously.
We have no idea.
But your son.
And the world that he's in.
I mean, do we have 50
women in the Senate?
Hopefully.
Have we had a woman president,
after woman president,
after a woman president, in
the '30s and '40s and onward?
You know what I'm saying?
And I think the lowest--
the thing that will
be the tie between all
of these successful women
will be because they played
sports because of Title IX.
- Definitely, I think it
will definitely be a big--
I'm sorry, playing
sports definitely
have a big impact on the success
of individuals in the future.
And I just know that
with my daughter,
I'm raising her to believe
she can do anything
that she wants to do.
She's super feisty.
And I like it.
That to me is like a
positive word in my house.
She has her own mind.
Now, it's a struggle for
me, don't get me wrong,
but I always have to remind
myself OK this is good.
I just have to shape
her and mold her,
because Sidney is like--
everything is like, I'm
going do what I want to do,
when I want to do it.
And she doesn't have
any limits on herself.
She says mom, I came out
of your boxing belly.
You know she's,
like doing this--
I don't want my daughter to
become a fighter, per se,
just because of the
business of boxing.
Like I mentioned, I wish that I
would've played sports earlier,
because I think I would have
been out there with Venus
and Serena, or out there on the
soccer field in the Olympics,
and I didn't even have
the opportunity to go
to the Olympics because boxing
was not-- female boxing--
was not an Olympic sport.
So men's boxing was.
My father got to go to the
Olympics, but I didn't.
So it now is, and there's
a young girl named
Claressa Shields who won gold.
And she--
- I think it twice.
- Yes, twice.
- '12 About 16.
- Yeah.
- Isn't a movie being made
about her life, I think?
- I know there was a
documentary made on her already,
but I don't know if
they're doing a movie,
but she's turned pro since then.
So I love just watching her.
She's actually in
the weight class
that I was in, so I love
watching her, and just watching
how her career is
unfolding, and I
try to give her some
advice along the way.
- But for me, my
daughter-- like I said.
I want her to play
sports, and get
everything she needs out of it.
And if she decides
that she wants to be
a professional athlete, great.
Because I think as
parents you have
to be careful not to push your
kids in a certain direction.
I want them to be open to do
whatever it is that's going
to make them happy in life.
So I'm going encourage
them to find that thing.
And yes, we're going
to play sports,
and you have to participate,
but you don't necessarily
have to become a
professional athlete.
It's just what you
take from sports
that can help you in so many
different areas of your life.
Your kids got to know
their grandfather.
- Oh yeah.
And they knew, but that they
didn't really understand.
Just like when I was a kid,
people always asked me,
when did you first learn
how great your father was,
or why people loved him?
And I can't even really
remember the moment,
but when I was eight or nine,
you don't really understand.
You understand people
are coming up to you,
everywhere you go
there's a crowd.
It's kind of annoying
because you're
standing around waiting
for a couple hours.
You get stuck everywhere.
I never wanted to go anywhere
with my dad because I knew--
he loved doing magic tricks
and drawing in a crowd.
So you're going to be there
for two or three hours watching
those same magic tricks.
- Did you ever figure
out the magic tricks?
- Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
He had this one where he would
pretend that this handkerchief
would disappear.
So he had a plastic thumb.
So he'd have the thumb, and he'd
say, here's the handkerchief.
And then he'd take
the thumb off,
and stuff the handkerchief
into the thumb,
and then put it back on.
So I saw that and
he'd say, oh, and then
as he got older and
got sick, the thumb
would be the wrong color.
He would have a
white person's thumb.
I like dad.
People could see it,
but they were still--
then he had this
levitating one that he
did where he'd act
like he was floating
and he really was
on his front toes.
So, like, I knew all of them.
As a child, you're just
like, oh, this is so corny.
But he would also pass out his
pamphlets, and he was still--
about Islam.
So he would write his signature.
And he spent hours
writing his signature
so that he could pass them out
to people as he met people.
So I saw this all the time.
And I get it now, but
as a kid I didn't ever
want to go with him.
I forget the question, again.
- It was about the kids
and looking up to him.
Of course, you lost your dad.
- Oh this is what I was
going to say, I'm sorry.
So my kids knew, but it
wasn't until he passed away
that they really got
the opportunity to see,
because now they're
showing all these specials
on my father on television.
We went to his memorial
service, and they
saw all these
different people come.
It was very
overwhelming for them,
and then they went to
the Muhammad Ali center
for the first time.
My son is older.
He's 8 now, and he's
really, really bright,
smart, and he was able to
just kind of watch the videos,
and see the timeline.
And I was even amazed
because I know my dad.
And I'm not a Muhammad Ali fan,
so I haven't read all of his
books-- of the books written
about him and all that--
but to be at the Ali center
and just see this long wall--
this timeline of all
these important dates,
and all of the things that
he's done in his life.
Because I never took the
time to really go through.
It was amazing to me.
And for them to see that, and
see all those wonderful people
get on the stage
and talk about him.
Then I could tell that when
they started to kind of get it.
And my daughter had this
really special connection--
like a spiritual
connection with my father--
ever since she was a baby.
- My father didn't really
speak that much anymore,
and towards the end, he
was in a hospital bed.
He was on a feeding
tube and all that.
And my daughter-- most
people-- or kids--
were afraid because
he's shaking,
he's got really big
hands, and my daughter,
since she was a baby would
just go right up to him,
hug him, and she'd kiss him,
and then she'd just kind of
get into the bed with him.
She'd run back and forth.
Every five minutes she'd go
back and visit him and kiss him
and his eyes would just light
up because he loves kids.
He loves giving kisses.
And for her not to
be afraid of him--
so it was amazing.
It was amazing to see
the connection they had.
That has been the hardest
thing for me is Sidney.
She doesn't understand.
Why did poppa have to leave?
Why did he have to go to heaven?
She's talking about him
still at least twice a week.
So she knows, but she doesn't
really understand why.
So it's going to be interesting
to see as they get older when
they really understand and
hear the stories of who
he was as a human being.
And I think they're going
to be even more proud.
But my son looks just like him.
So my son opened a
book the other day,
and was like, that
looks like me.
I'm like, I know.
When he was 12--
we've been telling him, you
look just like your grandfather.
And I love it because
I'm the youngest.
My dad has 13
grandkids, but my child
is the only one
that looks like him.
So I'm like, yeah.
- Good work.
Good work on that.
When we were
talking and chatting
about what we wanted
to talk about,
I mentioned the 1996 Olympics.
And I think because
for so many of us
it is that iconic
moment for your dad.
Those of us who didn't
really know him in his prime.
Obviously-- I remember
those Ali-Frazier fights,
but I was little, and
you weren't born yet.
But I was at the 1996
Olympics in Atlanta,
and I'm sure all of you
remember this moment,
but no one knew who was
going to light the torch.
And this is the US Olympics.
You figure it's going
to be a US athlete.
And lots of names
were thrown out.
But I don't even
remember your dad's name
being thrown out that much.
Michael Jordan,
all kinds of names.
So now comes the moment.
I'll set it up, but I want to
hear what you were thinking.
So now we're in the stadium,
opening ceremonies, 80,000
people.
It's dark and the torch is
going around, and Janet Evans--
of course, you remember Janet
Evans, the Olympic swimmer.
Now she's taking it up
to near where you're
going to light the cauldron,
and we're thinking, well,
it's Janet Evans, which is
not insignificant, and would
have been very well deserved--
Olympic gold medalist, and
a great Olympic champion,
a great athlete.
And then out of the
darkness emerges your dad.
And my last words
on this because
this is all your story--
my last words, though, as I'm
a journalist sitting there,
and we're all
there, I have never
heard 80,000 people
gasp in unison.
And it wasn't just me.
Bob Costas and I were
talking recently,
for a column about him.
And I said, what's your
favorite Olympic moment?
He's covered a lot
of them, as I have.
Mohammad Ali lighting the
torch is his favorite moment.
And he said the
same exact thing.
That audible gasp of like
the air being sucked out
of this outdoor
stadium as Muhammad Ali
emerged to light the torch.
- It was the same for me.
I mean we did not know we didn't
know our whole family didn't
know they kept such a secret.
You know it is-- if
you tell one person,
it might get to the other.
Our family is so big.
So we didn't even know.
So for me, I was
so proud of my dad,
and it just really
brought tears to my eyes.
- And you were-- you
were not in the stands.
- I was not there.
I wasn't there.
I was watching on television.
And I didn't know, so luckily
I saw it and caught it.
Sometimes you miss
those moments.
- How funny would
that have been?
Someone calls you, say,
hey were you watching TV?
No.
- Yeah, so that's me.
I'm that person that
would miss something.
It really just brought
tears to my eyes
because my father's never
hid the fact that he's sick.
He said that boxing was
going to be his platform
to do his humanitarian
work, and we already
know that he had an ego,
and he was conceited,
and he had a lot of pride,
and all those things,
but not so much that he
wouldn't get out and be
a symbol for other
people who had illnesses.
And he was still standing there
strong, even with his hand
shaking, and so I was
just proud of him.
Because he's such a sweetie pie.
That's the first thing I think
of when I think about my father
outside of just who he is
as a man, as an athlete,
is just how sweet and
gentle he is as a person.
So it just brought
tears to my eyes.
I don't really have a big
story other than that.
- That's a good one.
That's one of the best.
And will be, of course, iconic,
and the video is iconic,
and we saw it, of course, so
often when he passed away.
And, of course, our condolences
to you and your family on that.
Should we start the questions?
You want to do that?
- Why not?
Sure.
- We've got--
I believe we've got the
microphone here in the middle.
We'd love to hear your
questions and fire away.
Why don't you tell us who you
are and then ask your question.
Thank you.
- Sure.
Hi, I'm Sammy Nagy Chao,
I'm a master's student
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education,
and I have a real interest
in developing positive body
images in my students, whether
I'm coaching them or teaching.
So I just wanted
to get any thoughts
that you have on
developing positive body
images in all genders,
and especially
challenging a lot of ascetic
sports ideal body images.
- Well, for me I don't
have the ideal body
you would think as far as a
lot of women are concerned,
in general.
Because I'm a big girl.
A lot of times we're concerned
about our weight, and our size,
and all that.
I weighed 168 pounds
when I was fighting.
I weigh 190 pounds right now.
So that's the first thing a
lot of people are surprised at.
And I have no problem
saying it, because that's
one thing that I do.
I talk about it
openly just for people
to see that it doesn't really
matter how much you weigh.
It's really about how you feel.
And I try to focus
more on being healthy,
opposed to being
a certain size--
with eating right,
with working out
comes the benefit
of looking good.
So when you focus on that
then everything else kind of
falls into place.
And I think it really
just comes down
to understanding that we're
all special, we're all unique,
and that God created us
exactly the way that we're
supposed to be.
That's the first
foundation that you
have to have, and
stop looking at others
and wishing you
had what they had.
Because nobody's perfect.
A lot of people may look at me,
and think, oh, you're so this,
you're so that.
I can tell you, look, there are
things that if I could change--
the fact that I
wear size 12 shoe--
that right there,
I don't really care
that my feet are a size
12, the problem with it
is it's hard to find shoes.
So I have to order shoes
online, and I'm, ah.
So that's the thing.
But it's not because it's,
like, I'm embarrassed
because my feet are big.
They fit my body.
You know, and when
I was younger,
I was like, why are
my hands so big?
I got big hands.
You know, and it's hard
for me to find jewelry.
But then when I started
knocking people out,
I was like, thank you.
That's why.
Like I said, it's
just everything
is a way that is for a reason.
But, again, I don't have
the perfect answer for you,
but I think that
with a lot of girls,
they need to understand
when you see certain images,
people are airbrushed.
They're not even
the way they look
like they are a lot of the
time, but even for that person
you see in front of your eyes--
you're like, OK,
she's not airbrushed,
and she looks perfect to
You got to just accept what you
have, work with what you have,
and focus on the things
that are important.
And that's just a
message that we just
have to instill in people
on an ongoing basis.
But for me in my life I
focus on health and wellness
through nutrition
and working out.
I say build it, don't buy it.
Period.
- Thank you.
- How important is Serena
Williams in this conversation?
Because, again, I think one
of the greatest athletes
male/female ever in the United
States and the world, but also,
I think, the greatest female
athlete in any sport--
if we have to add the
adjective "female" to any
of this conversation.
But, again, the size where
what would have been said--
and she did deal with a lot--
- Yeah.
- But isn't it great that that
five-year-old, six-year-old,
7-year-old, girl or boy sees
that as the Sports Person
of the Year, right?
Isn't that exactly what
you're talking about?
- Yeah.
And her body is the way
that it is for a reason.
Look what she was born to do.
And not that everyone
has to aspire
to want to be that way or not.
I would have loved to go
against her because we're
both big, strong girls.
That's why I said, I'd
have something for them,
if I would have been
playing tennis--
I'm just playing.
I think it's great.
And I think that I love
her confidence in herself.
I love that she's able to be
comfortable in her own skin.
So regardless of what other
people think about her body,
and that's what's important.
That's what I admire when
I see other women who just
love themselves regardless.
But it's hard when you're on
that platform and everybody is
judging you.
I have people now
say about me, they're
like, listen to her voice.
She has such a deep
voice, sounds like a man.
Or maybe she took steroids.
And I'm like, say
that to my face.
No, I'm just joking.
- Well, thank you very much.
- I'm just playing.
Go on.
- Thank you.
Thanks for the question.
All right.
- My name is Anne Marie.
I'm a freshman at
Nichols College.
I was wondering what
was it like for you
when you realized that you were
a role model to so many people.
Was there a time where you're
like, oh my goodness, there's
so many people that look at me?
- I knew-- thank you.
I knew growing up--
I knew before I started
boxing that I would be a role
model because just
with my father being
who he is I understood that.
And I never wanted to
be a public person,
so that was one of the things
that I had to deal with when
I decided that I wanted to box.
A lot of just because
I grew up around it.
Some people want to be famous.
They're like, I
want to be famous,
I want people to recognize me.
I really don't like
being recognized.
I'm a private person.
I'd rather just not get
any attention, but for me--
so I had to deal
with it, and I said,
I've got to follow my
heart and do what I love,
and I wasn't really worried
about the role model side.
I get asked that
question a lot--
should athletes be role models?
You're naturally a role model,
whether you want to be or not,
but luckily, thank
God, I'm a person
that I'm going to do what's
right for the sake of doing
what's right, not because
I have to be a role model.
So it takes a burden
off of me, as well.
I don't have to
worry about that.
But, like I said, I do
make certain decisions
based on the fact that I
know people look up to me,
and I always remember
myself seeing
women's boxing
for the first time
and how that changed my life.
You know, so someone might
see me for the first time,
and it might encourage them
to do something in their life.
So that's pretty much it.
It's been really
natural for me, and I
think that it's not
the same for everyone.
Because some people
say, I don't want
to be a role model to your kids
just because I'm a basketball
player.
But that's just not
the way that it is.
You are a role
model, regardless.
- Thank you.
- Did I answer your question?
- That somebody--
Charles Barkley-- has admitted
that he is, in fact, a role
model.
- Oh, good.
- We had to hold him down
and tickle him, but he did.
I like that you mentioned that.
Next question.
- How are you guys today.
My name is Mike, I'm
better known as president.
I'm a 2008 a graduate
of the college,
and I study government here.
And these days
artist, entrepreneur,
and recently launched
a diverse ventures fund
to invest in women and
minority led businesses
in marginalized areas.
My first question would be--
what specific areas of the
economy of the sports world
do you think would have the
greatest macroeconomic impact--
and I ask that just watching
Warren Buffett's documentary
where he said that 50% of our
economy-- effectively women--
are being under utilized
from a macroeconomic stance.
So given that sports is such an
important part of our culture,
of our doctrine,
where specifically
can we put capital to
have the greatest impact?
- Oh brother, that's
just too deep for me.
- I got a thought for you.
- You just wore me out
with that question.
Back it up.
Look, I went to Santa
Monica College, OK?
I'm just joking.
Did you get all that?
- Well, I actually I
have an idea for you?
For you, but did you
have a second part first?
- My second part was, what
does balance mean to you?
- What?
- What does balance mean to you?
- Balance?
- Balance, yeah.
- I like that question.
- Something for everybody,
- Come on now.
- She'll take the
second part first.
Go ahead.
- Balance for me changes
from time to time.
But right now,
balance for me is--
I think of myself as a mother
first, a woman, a wife,
a business woman, an athlete--
and then I have
my spiritual self
that I'm thinking
about, so just trying
to balance all of those things.
So for me, it's just about being
the best mom that I can be.
Being the best
businesswoman I can be.
Doing everything-- I
have this thing about I
want to be a super
woman, but a lot of times
you fall short in certain areas.
So for me, it's really about
keeping my priorities in order,
really being consistent
about having a clear idea--
like every day, I
wake up and it's
like, these are my
goals for the day.
My long term, my short
term goals, and then
really checking
myself and making sure
that I stay on top of that,
because otherwise life happens.
People are pulling you
from every which direction,
and for me it's like
opportunities come up
where we want to give back as
an athlete, as a public person,
but then sometimes you get
so caught up giving back,
that you don't focus on
your own personal goals.
So for me like I
said balance really
is about just being consistent
and staying on top by writing
things down you know I have
affirmations that I say.
I meditate.
I have my short term
and long term goals,
and just kind of checking in
with that every single day.
But as far as that
other question?
- Well, OK.
But here, I've got an idea.
I've got an idea.
When you said the part about--
- He's just so tickled.
I like watching you.
You're so tickled.
- You were talking about the
under utilization of women,
and women as a power--
or economic force.
- Exactly.
- And so women's sports.
And one of the thoughts I have--
and maybe play off this or not--
is so when you see
all these shows,
and maybe it is even women
who are scantily clad,
which obviously I do
a lot of mentoring,
and I really try to encourage
people to have longevity, which
means if you're 25, can they
replace you with a 30-year-old?
But if you rely on your
brains and your talent,
you'll hopefully be doing
this into your 40s and 50s.
So there's that piece of it.
But if it's like ESPN--
not to pick on ESPN
at all, because they
have a ton of women on air--
but playing to the frat house
be it in hiring practices
or just what they're doing--
aren't they missing this
incredible demographic
of the 12-year-old girl on
the couch watching sports
with her mom or dad
or her siblings.
That 12-year-old girl-- again,
you can see my brain is always
moving ahead in
terms of the future--
12-year-old girl when she's
32 and making all the buying
decisions for the house whether
it's single person or married
or whatever-- and that, I think,
is where the mainstream sports
media has fallen terribly.
Not realizing that the frat
house is going to buy the beer,
but that 12-year-old
girl is going
to be a consumer of sports
for the rest of her life
because she's played
sports like your daughter,
like you, like I did, even, back
in the days of Rutherford B.
Hayes.
But that she will be not only
loving sports but a consumer.
And I know this is a huge
tenant of the Women's Sports
Foundation, is it not?
- Definitely.
I think we just need to see more
women over all areas of media
and television.
I co-host a show
called We Need to talk.
It's and all-female
sports commentary show.
And I work with so many talented
women, journalists, and also
other athletes.
And it's just like
any other show.
- Great show.
If you haven't seen it,
Leslie Visser, of course,
dear friend of mind.
- Oh, yeah, right.
- It's CBS Sports Network.
- CBS Sports Network and
its called We Need to Talk,
but that's the type of
show that I want to see.
And we have a female
producer, and director,
and it's always a great show.
So I think that has been a
start it has been wonderful,
and it's been getting a
lot of positive feedback.
But I think that just
infusing more women
into every area of
every thing is always
going to make it better.
- Well, and Billie
Jean King, again,
who we've mentioned
before has always said,
we've got to have women
making the decisions
at the top of these companies
and the top of these networks
so that then they're
hiring more women,
and it all starts
to balance out.
So that's our answer.
That's all we got.
- Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
And I just wanted to add.
I didn't know too
much about my dad.
He passed when I was growing
up when I was very young,
but I was watching Facing
Ali and I saw him in there,
and I saw that he was on
security with our father,
and I found a lot
of my purpose in it.
So thank you for being here,
just allowing me to even heal
and grow into a better person
just in this whole interaction.
I appreciate you guys so much.
Thank you.
- Wow.
That's a great story.
- That's a small world.
That's really cool.
- That's cool.
Thank you.
- Hi I'm [? Paren ?]
Grayson, and I'm a graduate
of Radcliffe College.
And when I was here, I had the
chance to hear your father.
He came to speak, and he was
brilliant-- read his poetry,
and it's a very special memory.
But I had a question.
I would be fascinated to
hear what was involved
in training to become a boxer.
Because I have--
- Yes.
- Very little idea.
- Yes, I'll tell you.
So before I started
boxing-- like I said,
I didn't play sports.
I wasn't in shape at all.
I was like any other person--
I shouldn't say
any other person,
but I was like most young kids.
I ate what I wanted to eat.
I didn't have a gym
membership or anything.
At that time I was
about 17 and 1/2.
So I went down to the boxing
gym, got with a trainer,
and they say, well, you've got
to come to the gym six days
a week.
And what I would do
when I got to the gym
is I would hit the heavy bag.
You know what a heavy bag is?
I would hit the speed bag.
There's a double in bag
to work on your eyes,
jump roping, then, of
course, do your sit ups
and you do all
that kind of stuff.
And then you work
with your trainer
on your footwork in the ring.
Every fighter is different, I'll
say, but those are the basics.
And you really have
to take the time
to assess what your
strengths are as a fighter.
So naturally, if you're tall,
and you have a long reach,
you're going to work on
keeping somebody on the outside
because you can hit them,
but they can't hit you.
They have shorter arms.
But that's not as
easy as it sounds.
And then for me, I
had to start running.
Because I never ran.
And you have to do your
roadwork as a fighter
because boxing is one of
the hardest sports when
it comes to endurance because,
again, you might be getting
beat up, and you still
have to keep going
and that takes a lot of strength
in a lot of different areas
of your body, not only mentally,
but physically, as well.
So learning how to run
I think was probably
one of the things I
was most proud of.
- How far would you run?
- I started off walking running.
And it's funny because my
mom has always been very fit.
And she taught me how to run.
So we went out and
we ran and she said,
OK, we're going to
run for a minute,
and then we're going to
walk for two minutes.
We're going to run for a minute,
and I kind of worked my way up.
And that's what
I tell people now
they say they don't
know how to run.
I didn't know how
to run, either.
So I had to teach myself.
And then I worked my
way up to four miles,
because depending on
how many rounds you're
fighting, when you
first start fighting,
your first fight
would be four rounds.
So for me, running
for miles was enough.
Some fighters might say
they'll run eight miles,
but you don't really need to .
depending on what your
style of fighting is.
But that's it.
And then just every day
doing that back to back,
working your way up--
a lot of shadowboxing.
Just being in the
mirror, pretending
there's someone in
front of you and they're
throwing a certain
shot and you're
getting out of the way of it.
And then eventually
you start sparring,
which is when you
actually get in the ring
and box with other fighters.
So that's always an
interesting experience
to start doing that because
you're going to get beat up
a little bit the first time.
And I only boxed with
men, for the most part.
When I first started boxing,
I boxed with some women,
but it was hard to
find-- it's harder
to find girls who are tall
enough and weigh enough,
because boxing is
all by weight class,
and if you box
with a man, you've
got to find a man
who is lighter,
and who knows how to
work with you, who's not
going to be hitting you
as hard as he possibly can
because a man is always going
to be stronger than a woman.
Most men, anyway.
I've had some that weren't,
but anyway, it was fun.
That's pretty much it.
But you have to
understand the pain
that your body goes through--
I'm not talking about being
hit, just the next day
is when you really feel it.
When you're sore from
being hit, and then
you have to get in there
and do it again day
after day after day.
It's really a mental--
you have to be strong
mentally, as well,
to get in there because
if you are getting hit,
and you keep getting
hit with the same shot,
and you're in the round, and
you can't figure out why.
I'd get so mad sometimes
I would just cry.
I wouldn't like--
but I'd have tears
because I'd be so mad
trying to figure out
what I was doing wrong.
But I would still keep fighting.
I'd be crying and fighting.
People thought I was crazy
lots of times in the gym.
I may be crying, but I'm
going to keep fighting.
So yeah, but it was a
grueling workout, definitely.
Thank you.
- Thanks, [INAUDIBLE]
- Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE] from the
Ecole Polytechnique in Paris.
And thank you very
much for coming.
What would be the most
inspirational quote
from your father you
will always remember?
- I think, and I'm
going to paraphrase it.
Service on earth
is the rent that I
pay for my space in heaven.
So basically, the service
that he's doing now,
he felt like was
his way into heaven.
And he believed
that, by the way,
which was interesting to me.
Because my father was always--
he believed that you've got
to do more good than you
do bad to make it to heaven.
I'm just thinking, wow, this
man who has done so much
and changed the world, and
inspired so many lives feels
like he still has
more good to do,
as far as in terms of
making it to heaven.
But he really was all about just
giving back to other people,
and he loved people.
I've seen my father
just over the years
get what you would think
taken advantage of by people,
but he didn't care.
Because if someone stole from
him or something, he's like,
well he must have needed
it more than I did.
And I'm just like,
that's not how I think.
So we're very
different in that way.
But my father is just such
a giving, loving person,
and I grew up watching
my father cry.
I watched that,
and that, for me,
made a big difference in
who I was as an individual
because seeing a man
as strong as Muhammad
Ali in those moments
when he's crying--
not because he felt bad,
but just even out of joy
or because he was sad.
And he was very
sensitive and wasn't
afraid to show his feelings.
So that when I said he
was a male chauvinist
in a certain way not
in that way, though,
so that was something that I
really loved and appreciated
about my father.
So yes, it was all
about service to others.
And he has a quote--
we got to look up
that exact quote.
- Maybe someone's
got their phone.
- OK.
- Thank you.
- And I was thinking off of
that question-- you know,
your dad is so associated
with Howard Cosell,
and Howard Cosell has
been gone for a long time,
but I'm curious, have you ever
dealt with the Cosell family?
You probably never
met Howard Cosell.
- No.
- But all those interviews--
you guys remember those?
And, I'm so pretty, and
all that back and forth.
I mean, your dad
obviously would have
been your dad without
Howard Cosell,
but I think Howard
Cosell brought out--
- They had a fun relationship
for sure, the two of them
together.
- And there's some great
comments from those interviews,
too, if you want to
look them up, for sure.
Next question.
- Hi my name is Ariel, and
I'm a senior at the college.
And I was just wondering-- this
is kind of for both of you--
how have you learned
from your identity
being an athlete and the
things through practicing sport
for your whole life
onto your career,
and how has that shaped the
person that you are today,
and the professional
decisions you've made?
- For me, boxing
changed my life,
because there's lots of moments
where you really have to--
just being an athlete,
you've got to dig deep,
and that's when you really
find out who you are.
And naturally, as human beings,
we put limits on ourselves.
We think, oh, we
can't go any further.
I can't push any harder.
And then you're in a situation
where you have to do it,
and you're like, oh, I did it.
And I remember that moment when
I thought that I couldn't, and
then I remember that moment
when I found out that I could,
and then now I can apply that
to everything else in my life.
And any time that I just
think, this is too hard,
I'm not going to
be able to do it.
I'm like, what are
you talking about?
Yes, you can.
So that alone in itself is just
that confidence that I have
that I've proven to myself.
If I've proven to
myself one time,
that means I can prove it to
myself a million more times.
So that is just the
most basic thing
I can tell you about
how being an athlete
has just changed my life in
the way that I look at things.
It doesn't mean that you're
not going to have failures.
It doesn't mean that things
aren't going to be hard,
but just having the
confidence and the self-belief
to know that I can
pretty much get
through just about anything.
And I think that
that is so important.
People need confidence
more than ever.
So many people have
good ideas and things
that they want to do, but
the fear holds them back.
Like I said, I can't speak
to how sports really--
I mean, the women that I
know that are athletes just
have this level of confidence.
You can just see it.
You can fill it.
You can hear it.
And they can apply it.
- Well, and you
think about this--
for generations in this country,
we were not allowing 50 or 51%
of our population to
learn these life lessons.
What were we thinking?
Again, Title IX, signed by
Richard Nixon, of all people,
in June of 1972.
- But I graduated from high
school in '76, so I was
starting high school in '72,
and so I really saw almost none
of it.
Grew up in the suburbs
of Toledo, Ohio,
and I was a six-sport
athlete in high school.
And now you think, oh
she's a great athlete.
No.
I was good enough, and I'm
tall, and so I was able to play,
and I was coordinated.
But no one cared
about girls sports.
Even my dad, who was my own
personal Title IX playing
baseball with me when
I was growing up.
But no one cared enough
about girls sports
to want us to specialize.
So I literally ran from first
doubles on the tennis court,
to the field hockey match where
I was the captain of the team,
and then basketball
and volleyball
in the winter, and then
softball and track and field
in the spring.
- In my high school, 100%
of the kids went to college,
and every mom and dad
wanted their daughter
to be a doctor or a lawyer, just
like their son, except sports.
To show how ingrained
this was, no one
even thought that we were
mowing the field hockey
field while our
opponent was showing up.
This was a Tuesday, where
the football field--
what would that be--
72 hours away was already
in pristine shape.
And yet the field
hockey team was
the one that was sending
kids onto college
and winning Ohio
State championships,
my high school did.
And the football team
has had like two boys
be kickers in college, which is
great, but it was so ingrained.
And so for me, in addition
to just the pure love of all
those sports, and to this day
I play sports and love it,
and it's just a lifetime thing,
as I'm sure for most of you
in this room.
But I also think, for me, it
has informed every ounce of what
I do as a journalist
because I know what
it was like to have
it myself because
of my parents
encouraging it at a time
when no one else was encouraging
their daughter to play sports.
And so I had that, but
most women my age--
and so to fight for Title
IX, to write those columns,
to ask the questions as I
just did at Augusta National
about Donald Trump and women.
I will absolutely do that.
Yeah, look it up.
You might your
computer might explode.
- And I'm going back
tonight to drive them crazy.
But anyway, but bottom line
is that as a journalist having
seen this incredible
change, it's fantastic.
And it makes me smile,
and brings tears
to my eyes to see
what girls have now,
and how wonderful the change
has been in a blink of an eye
in our nation's history.
Thank you for your question.
- Hello, my name
is Amanda Ortiz,
and I'm a student athlete at
University of Massachusetts.
My question was
regarding the inequality
of women professional
athletes, and I
guess regarding basketball
and soccer, relatively.
Your thoughts and personal
experiences on that.
- I don't have any personal
experience with it.
I know that the Women's Sports
Foundation does a lot of work
with collegiate sports
and trying to make sure
that the playing field
is leveled as far as just
dollars that are
allocated to the girls
so that we have the same amount
opportunities as the boys'
teams do.
Do you have anything?
- Yeah, and think we can
declare victory with Title IX
because of the participation
piece of it where literally
if a girl-- if you see
a girl in the airport,
what sport do you play?
You never would have asked
that question 40 years ago.
So we've done so
many good things.
Obviously the
under-served areas,
and women coaching women
is where we're really--
and Mary Jo Kane has done a lot
on this, and the Tucker Center,
you guys do amazing work.
So there's a lot
to go on that side.
So it's not all--
I said declare victory
because I want to be positive,
but there's a lot to do there.
The professional
side-- in some ways,
of course, that's business, and
if people want to pay for it.
So while I think the WNBA
is great and, for example,
in DC where Elena Delle Donne
has now come to Washington,
that is going to be a very
big deal in Washington.
And the Mystics
will do very well.
But the Wizards are so
entrenched, of course,
they're not going to
overtake the Wizards.
That would be
ridiculous to say that.
And that's OK.
I think my-- and we
want to make sure--
we have a few minutes.
Want to make sure to get to
as many questions as possible.
Books are written on
this topic, and Mary Jo
would be a great one
to talk to, but I
do think that we judge women's
sports by the male model.
And if you listen to shock
jock screaming radio, like,
oh WNBA isn't any good and
whatever-- well, you know what?
Could we start baseball today
if there was no baseball?
Of course not.
A sport that never existed
and now corporations
are going to build
stadiums to have baseball?
No.
So the bottom line
is women's sports
are coming into a chock
full calendar of sports,
and I think they're doing great.
And in 100 years,
we'll be equal?
Probably not, but maybe.
But there's also
things like gymnastics,
where the women are the stars.
Figure skating where
women are the stars.
Soccer where our women's
team is certainly much more
successful than our men's team.
On and on it goes.
And I think, again, you
look for those moments,
but there's a lot on
that topic and feel free
to shoot me an email if
you want at my website.
I'm happy to discuss
it further with you.
- Thank you.
- I am Sharon Turbin,
I'm a sports psychologist
in the area, and I could go
off in 10 different directions
on some things that
you've said, Laila.
One is that you were a
late initiator in terms
of becoming an athlete
in your own mind,
and I think there is an
upside to that, which
is you weren't
necessarily shaped
by that male model,
which you just described.
And as women internalize the
values of sport that are still
getting communicated
primarily by male coaching,
there is a humanity about you,
and the fact that you started
later, you already had command
of lots of parts of yourself.
And I think doing some--
you are a role model,
so modeling that
initiation as an athlete
can occur all
through the lifecycle
is actually a pretty
big statement.
I worked with a power
lifter who started at 50
and competed at
the national level.
Not age weighted.
Like, she competed full
strength at 50 years old.
It's pretty compelling for
people later in the life cycle
to have models of
later initiation
and not to be necessarily
apologetic about not having
been an athlete in the
developmental years,
and all of the upside
that that kids do get
from being in the sports world.
And then my other
question to you is do you
speak to those groups--
to women who potentially
haven't necessarily
identified as an
athlete, but are looking
for ways to do that
sort of midlife,
or throughout the life cycle?
- I haven't up until this point.
No one's ever
asked me to either,
but I think that for me
being that boxing is just
so different than
other sports, I
was able to get into it late
because of the level of women's
boxing, or just
boxing in general.
It's one of those sports.
It's not organized.
Anyone can be like,
I want to be a boxer,
any would can say I
want to be a promoter.
And I don't really like the
business side of boxing,
but I always want to
put that in perspective,
because I can't-- like now, I
wouldn't have been able to just
get in and just start playing.
I could, but I'm saying
like tennis or something
like that because people
have-- their skill level
is so much greater because
they started sooner.
So I wouldn't have
been able to do that.
And that's why I, like I
said, that I regret it.
I'm not one of those people
who wants to go back and go,
I don't care if
I'm 40, I'm going
to start playing tennis now.
You know, I'm just
like, I'm good.
So I'm good, next lifetime.
I'm all for people who want
to do that, though, but you
definitely have to be
passionate about it,
and you have to be prepared.
I have other goals
and dreams that I
want to attain
because people ask
me now do I want to come
back and train fighters.
Do I want to come back
and promote fights.
I'm like, that's
not my interest.
And that's not
something I'm going
to apologize for either,
because the women's boxing
community says,
well why don't you
come back and do
more for us, and I'm
like, that's not my passion.
I have a passion
to really encourage
people to be the best that they
can be in life, whether they're
an athlete or not.
I'm not going to just limit
myself to just boxing.
If I can just help and
come in and get out--
get in and get out--
I can, but to answer
your question,
I would be open to doing that.
Any time that I
can say something
that can help somebody else,
that's what I want to do.
As far as what I'm
going to make my focus,
that comes down to
what's in my heart,
but definitely--
if you're asking me
if I'd be interested to speak,
then yes, I would, definitely.
So, thank you.
- Thank you, and you know what?
We're going to do--
we're going to go to overtime.
We are we're
actually out of time,
but we're going to do a
lightning round where we're
going to do like literally 30.
Seconds can you guys do that?
- Yes.
- OK.
You're up.
- I'm Diane Rosenfeld.
I teach at the law school and
run the Gender Violence Program
there.
And thank you for coming.
And I wanted to bring
your dad into the room.
I had the honor of
meeting him in '94.
- Can you bring it up.
- Yeah, absolutely
I'll bring it up--
- Oh, after you say
what you're saying.
And what really struck me about
him that is living through you
is he had so much grace.
And I see that in
you, and thank me
for all your amazing
work and inspiration.
- I appreciate that.
And my very quick question
is I pay a lot of attention
to gender equality in
sports and eliminating
sexual harassment,
and sexual assault,
and that angle of
Title IX, and I'm
wondering what you think
about gender inclusive sports
as a way to address the
sexism that exists in sports.
That if kids grew up
playing with each other,
and it wasn't like a boys
team and a girls team.
- Your kids are now, right?
- Yeah, I was going to say.
- Your daughter's playing on
your son's Little League team.
- So she plays on my
son's baseball team--
- And we're going to
keep this to 30 seconds.
- Yeah, I know.
So I see on the field--
my son plays soccer.
I see girl's teams,
which is great.
And I see some teams
where the girls
are playing with the boys,
and I think that's wonderful.
I think as long as it's
not a sport where power
is going to come into play.
Like a lot of times
people say, would you
ever want to fight a
man, and I'm like no,
because I want to win.
I'm not going to fight a man--
not that my skill
level isn't as high
but the thing is I punch
harder than a lot of men,
but they can take it,
and I start wearing down
when they start hitting me.
It's just the way that it is.
There's nothing wrong with that.
That's the way God created us.
So if it's a sport where we
literally can be equal, then
definitely.
Like Billie Jean King
and her wonderful--
- Beating Bobby Riggs.
- Yeah, she beat him.
And he was a man.
So in some cases, I would say,
no, I don't want to see that.
But for the most part, I think
it would be great, definitely.
- OK, thanks.
- Thank you.
All right.
Quick, quick, quick.
Here we go.
- Matt Myerson from Mentor.
And Laila, we had
the opportunity
to record a mentoring a video
together in Los Angeles where
you had a young girl who was
mentoring you in your journey.
And it was interesting because
my life has been dedicated
to trying to promote
mentoring, and the idea of you
doing one event.
- Oh, I'm like,
don't I know you.
- Yes.
- This is your life, Laila Ali.
- So it's been interesting for
me sitting here and thinking
how I'm dedicating my life to
trying to encourage more people
to sign up and become mentors.
And you spent an
hour recording a PSA,
and promoted on your social,
and the impact that that had.
And would love to
hear from both of you
for a minute in terms of what
you want your legacy to be.
Both have mentioned
mentoring as something
that's meaningful to you,
but when people look back
on you in 20 or 30 or
40 years of your life--
not your boxing life-- but your
personal life and your impact,
what do you want your legacy
to be for both of you?
- Well I'll go first, because
we want her to close the show.
It's a very nice question.
I do more mentoring
than anything
else these days in
writing, talking, anything.
And I've started several
scholarships, including
in my late parents' names.
About six now each year with
Northwestern, my alma mater,
in Toledo, and with
the Association
of Women in Sports Media, our
women's sports media group.
It is very friendly with the
Women's Sports Foundation.
And just helping young
people get into sports media,
especially women.
And we have thousands of
women now covering sports
in this country, where we
only had a few when I started.
So it's just hoping
that kids can
reach their dreams, especially
young girls and women
through sports.
So that's among several
things, but that certainly
is right up there for me.
Thank you very much.
And all you.
Yes.
- It's funny.
I haven't really given that
question serious thought.
You might have think I have.
I feel like I'm right
in the thick of it
right now, and still figuring
out a lot of things for myself
and about myself, but I
can say that giving back
is very important to me.
Inspiring others
is important to me.
I grew up in a very
dysfunctional family.
A lot of people
don't realize that.
When my parents got divorced,
my mom got remarried,
and I went through a lot.
And a lot of that is what turned
me into the fighter that I am.
So I've learned a lot
about myself along the way.
And I always try to
now just try to let
others know that you never
can judge a book by its cover.
We know that that saying,
and a lot of people
would assume that I grew up
with a silver spoon in my mouth,
and that wasn't the case.
So I literally had
to fight from a kid,
and I'm still fighting now.
Now that I retired from
boxing, and I'm like, OK,
I need to rebrand myself.
I don't want to just be
the fighter because now I'm
in this boxing box
of first it was like,
I need to be taken seriously,
and now it's like, oh,
I want to do TV and cross
over, and I have this fitness
and wellness brand.
And sometimes I can seem
intimidating to people,
and I'm like wow.
So it's really about
finding balance
and I'm always fighting.
But I just want to really
help as many other people
as I can along the way while
still being true to myself.
I don't think that there's
anything wrong with wanting
certain things for yourself.
And then figuring out what
God put me on earth for,
make myself happy,
and do the work
that I'm here to do, and bring
others along the way with me.
So I'm never going to just
have all the clear answers.
I'm still figuring things
out, but if I can help others
with things that I do know, and
things that I have figured out,
then great.
But I never like to
come from a place
like, oh, I got it
all figured out.
I'm going to be 40
years old soon--
December 30.
- Kid you.
- I'm excited about it.
A lot of people are like--
they worry about getting
older, but I'm just
happy to be healthy,
and have a family,
and have so many different
opportunities before me.
And I really do feel like I can
do anything that I want to do,
it's just a matter of
deciding what I want to do.
And I'm really blessed--
I know to even just have
that kind of confidence,
and I know that it came
through my parents.
And it came from
them by example.
My dad didn't sit down and
have conversations with me
about how to be confident,
how to believe in myself.
He just believed in himself.
He was confident in himself.
And the language that we
speak-- the way we speak about
ourselves, the way we
speak about others,
the conversations that we
have in our household--
kids learn from watching.
So for me, I want to
be there for my kids.
And I want to be that for
anybody else watching me.
Something that I say today
might spark something
in an individual and
change their life.
So that's all.
don't I can't say--
I don't have a two sentence
answer for that, but whatever
you can take from that.
That's it.
That's all I can say.
- How great.
- I hate to end that way.
- That was fantastic.
That was good.
- Thanks.